how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today I have a very special video for
you today and yes it does involve the
Fantastic Four and not only does it
involve the Fantastic Four but it also
involves Galactus the Silver Surfer and
Nova ever since Kevin Feige name dropped
the Fantastic Four at San Diego
comic-con this year fans have been going
crazy and have been wondering when
exactly are we going to see them and
although I can't tell you exactly when
they're going to be making their MCU
debut I can tell you a little bit about
what Marvel is thinking of for their
story when they finally do enter the MCU
thanks to an exclusive scoop from Mikey
Sutton so welcome to the first part of
the Mikey
Sutton scoop jam as his way of saying
thank you to the community and the
youtubers who have supported him he has
given each of us an exclusive scoop for
today and mine involves the Fantastic
Four and the one and only man on fire
Johnny Storm so let's dive into it but
first be sure to subscribe when
notifications turned on to leave a like
and comment on the video to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 according to Mikey Sutton and
his sources the man on fire is in love
Johnny Storm has fallen for a new girl a
gorgeous redhead named Frankie Rey now I
know the comic book fans know who
Frankie Rey is and if you caught the
Fantastic Four and the rise of the
Silver Surfer film you probably know who
Frankie Rey is as well although if you
just know her from the film as a
military officer there's a lot about her
that you probably don't know and we'll
get into that in just a bit
according to Mikey one of the priorities
for Marvel Studios when they debut the
Fantastic Four into the MCU is to flesh
out the characters and ways that Fox
didn't do now clearly this makes perfect
sense fans weren't exactly too excited
with the way that Fox handled the
Fantastic Four especially the most
recent one the biggest one of course
being how Fox depicted Galactus as a
cloud one of the biggest baddest
villains in Marvel history with a very
distinguishable look was a cloud
so of course Marvel is going to want to
do with these characters something that
Fox didn't do and the scoop goes on to
say there are several decades of comic
books that Marvel Studios will pull from
they're thinking of building up Rey as
Johnny's dream girl his Mary Jane if you
will the Fantastic Four is still in
early development
but Ray is on their radar after the
Silver Surfer is introduced as The
Herald of Galactus it is a job that
Norrin Radd doesn't have for long and
for anybody who may not know Norrin Radd
is the Silver Surfer now some of you may
know where this is going if you have
read this comic run so Galactus and his
Herald the Silver Surfer will be
introduced to the MCU but the Silver
Surfer won't be his Herald for long but
who will take his place and there lies
the tragedy of Johnny's love for Rey as
she becomes Galactus 'iz new Herald just
like she did and John Burns classic 80s
Fantastic Four comics frankie ray
appeared in the Fantastic Four the rise
of the Silver Surfer but Marvel Studios
wants to make her soar as a cosmic power
one that could provide a challenge for
even Captain Marvel and that's the scoop
from Mikey Sutton and this makes a lot
of sense the fact that Marvel is
reportedly thinking about bringing in
Frankie ray to the first Fantastic Four
film in the MCU opens up the storyline
to so many different possibilities I'm
talking about Galactus the Silver Surfer
and even her run as Nova now I know a
lot of people probably don't know who
Frankie ray is so let me explain her
origin and how she ties into all of
these different storylines and all of
these different major characters and how
she could go on to become one of the
most powerful characters in the MCU and
The Herald of Galactus in the comics
Frankie's father left her and her mother
when she was young her mother then
remarried to a man named Thomas Rey her
mother would end up passing away and she
was left under the care of her stepdad
Thomas ray Thomas ray worked in a
laboratory as a hobby and Frankie Rey
would help him in the lab Thomas Rey
found out about the Fantastic Four when
they appeared and he found out about the
Human Torch and went into a rage and the
reason he went into a rage is because
unknown to Frankie his real name was
Phineas Horton Phineas Horton was the
creator of the very first Human Torch
Android during World War two and that's
why the Human Torch a real Human Torch
absolutely infuriated him the government
would end up shutting down Phineas's
research and put the Human Torch Android
into a warehouse well when Horton found
out about the Human Torch he went to the
warehouse with Ray and while carrying
some bottles of chemicals containing
horton cells ray fell through
some weak planks and when she failed the
chemicals broke and they doused her and
when they doused her she burst into
flames
not only did Rey survive but she found
that she could create flames with her
body just like the human torch and could
even control fires Horton was horrified
and in an attempt to protect her from
alienation that he had seen the first
human torch undergo he hypnotized her
and ordered her to forget the experience
and even made her develop a pyro phobia
a fear of fire he also created a
transparent suit for her that suppressed
her powers and then he hypnotically
ordered her to ignore the suit acting as
if it wasn't even there and to keep her
from furthering finding out about her
powers and the experience he sent her to
live on her own at just 14 years old she
lived on her own but Horton sent a check
every month and she lived a relatively
normal life through high school but that
all changed when she ran into Johnny
Storm and the Fantastic Four
Frankie had essentially become a human
torch due to this accident and her
subconscious drew her to Johnny Storm
and despite her pyro phobia the two of
them ended up meeting and when they met
they began a relationship now Johnny
eventually became aware of her
transparent suit that she wore all of
the time and of course Frankie was
hypnotized to where she didn't even know
that she was wearing it or that it even
existed so of course she denied the fact
that she was even wearing one because
according to her own brain she wasn't
now of course this big mystery of this
transparent suit that Frankie didn't
even know existed sparked the curiosity
of Johnny so he went to Reed Richards
mr. fantastic for help mr. fantastic
would soon solve the mystery and he even
released her from her hypnotic trance
and after she was released Sue Storm The
Invisible Woman and sister to Johnny
convinced mr. fantastic to let Frankie
joined the Fantastic Four as another
Human Torch she joined the Fantastic
Four and learned how to control her
powers but of course that is not where
the story ends Galactus would soon come
to earth now at this point Galactus had
made an oath to spare earth however he
had become very weak and felt like he
had no other choice but to consume earth
otherwise he would die ray however saw
an opportunity to save Earth and to
emulate both of her father's by
abandoning earth just as they abandoned
her so she volunteered to become
Galactus as Herald now
course Frankie did this to save earth
and Galactus agreed to this proposal
because it allowed him to keep his oath
to not consume earth Galactus gave ray
the power cosmic and she became Nova ray
would go on to lead Galactus to many
different planets causing billions of
people to die however she was very
apathetic to all of these people dying
she didn't really care that much this
attracted the attention of Galactus as
previous Herald the Silver Surfer the
Silver Surfer and Frankie rave would
become friends and her apathy towards
the billions of people dying reminded
him of his apathy when he served as the
Herald of Galactus as well the Silver
Surfer showed Frankie a world and then
he asked her if she would choose it for
her master when she said yes he
confessed that he had taken her back in
time and shown her her own planet Earth
she then of course realized what she was
doing and all of a sudden had compassion
her compassion made her useless to
Galactus so he stripped her of her power
cosmic and then he replaced her with
Mord Frankie and the Silver Surfer
became companions along with all of the
other former heralds of Galactus all of
the former heralds got together and
fought against the current Herald of
Galactus morgue trying to ensue that
Galactus could no longer consume planets
during this battle morgue would end up
killing Frankie ray by blasting her from
behind as a punishment for this Galactus
stripped morg of the power cosmic which
enabled his former heralds to eventually
kill him the Silver Surfer would end up
in to mean Nova's body into a star now
recently it's been shown that she's
actually not dead and she has returned
to earth to be with Johnny Storm
and of course Marvel doesn't ever take
something from the comics and make it a
direct adaptation into a movie but as
you can see there is just plenty of
material here for Frankie ray to be a
part of the Fantastic Four's movie
including the introduction of Galactus
which we know is going to be coming in a
Fantastic Four film and the Silver
Surfer which of course we know is going
to be coming as well and of course let's
not forget the old Avengers tower in New
York and spider-man fire from home by
the time Spiderman far from home was
over this new building had completed
construction and was complete now a lot
of people are thinking that this could
be Oscorp tower and of course it could
be however given everything that was
going on with the spider-man a Sony
Marvel deal Marvel may not have been too
eager to
just assumed that they could bring
norman osborn into the MCU
however the Disney Fox deal had been
completed and Marvel can now officially
use the Fantastic Four in the MCU so
Marvel has one thing that is not for
sure Norman Osborn and another that is
for sure that fans would absolutely
freak out about the Fantastic Four so
this could very well be the Baxter
building which of course is the
headquarters the top floors at least to
the Fantastic Four so we know that the
Fantastic Four are headed to the MCU
Kevin Feige has confirmed this at San
Diego comic-con and again according to
Mikey Sutton Marvel is thinking about
bringing Frankie R a storyline in to the
Fantastic Four when they debuted the MCU
if Marvel decides to go this route it
opens up a ton of different
possibilities very very exciting
possibilities so let me know what you
think about this would you like Marvel
Studios to incorporate the story of
Frankie Rey in the MCU in a Fantastic
Four film let me know what you think in
the comments down below and again
another thank you to mikey sutton for
this exclusive awesome scoop for more of
his scoops you can be sure to check out
Lords of the long box on their YouTube
channel again don't forget to like this
video comment down below and subscribe
when notifications turned on so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 the winner gets to
choose I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
if you'd like to chance to win an
Infinity Gauntlet you can click the link
in the description down below and don't
forget to use code cosmic at G feel calm
for 30% off G fuel as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll forth